you know what's amazing too isn't Kruger
in the movie like eight minutes no yeah
you know that it's well
tied for the most least amount of screen
time with biggest impact no way seven
minutes the minute is an hour and 52 an
hour and 52 minutes and he's in seven
minutes isn't that insane he's doing a
quick math yeah that means one hour and
he's in the movie six percent of the
movie I'm insane that's insane talk
about making an impact to the character
right seven minutes well I was
traumatized seven minutes now I
literally I literally dehydrated myself
and I literally dehydrated myself and
sucked in eight hours of CO2 a night for
one year because of that seven minutes
bad seven minutes yeah